So, at this point, we know that the quote variable must have been set to true at some point.
Because initially it was false, but we already know that if it had stayed false,
then the less than character would never have been added to the output.
So we now have deduce that quote must have been set,
and there is only one place in the program where quote is set, which is down here.
So we can deduce that this long condition, which checks for quote,
must have held at some earlier point before the less than sign.
Why must it have been true at some earlier point?
Well, because at the moment when symbols left was the less than sign
then the condition did not hold
That simply assumed it was the character right before the less than sign
then the variable tag had never been set to true.
It was false from the beginning and it was false till the very end.
If you look at this condition, what was the value of c and again over to you.